-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden made a surprise
trip last week to Ukraine
by taking a 10-hour train ride,
or as the guy next to him
thought,
an 80-hour train ride.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden reportedly
had a difficult time sleeping
last week on the overnight train
ride from Poland to Ukraine
and read a briefing memo
on the history of Kyiv
and that didn't
put him to sleep?
That would have
put the last president
into a multi-year coma.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview,
President Biden said
that he has
"other things to finish
before launching a full-blown
presidential campaign."
Like, for instance,
"Yellowstone."
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
then-President Trump
was so upset with "Late Night"
host Jimmy Kimmel's criticism
that he asked
White House staffers
to call Disney executives.
And he was apparently so upset
with me that he called my boss.
-That's right, Seth.
I told him to get lost.
[ Laughter ]
-Good looking out, Wally.
Thank you.
-You're welcome. Yep.
-Vice President Kamala Harris
spoke today in South Carolina
about the Biden
administration's expansion
of high-speed Internet access.
Although, it didn't help matters
that the live stream
started like this.
[ Modem dialing ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Dialing stops ]
An-n-n-nd we're live.
[ Laughter ]
House Republicans reportedly
planning to hold hearings
on the Biden administration's
response
to the toxic train wreck
in East Palestine, Ohio.
And one way or another,
they're going to figure out
how Hunter Biden
sabotaged that train.
[ Laughter ]
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis'
book "The Courage to be Free"
is set to be released tomorrow.
Look for it
wherever books are legal.
[ Laughter ]
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
held a three-day retreat
over the weekend for top donors
and supporters
at the Four Seasons
in Palm Beach.
For a $10,000 donation,
you got to meet him.
And for $20,000, you didn't.
[ Laughter ]
An alligator
was recently captured
in Brooklyn's Prospect Park
and taken to the Bronx Zoo.
You made it move from Brooklyn
to the Bronx?
[ Laughter ]
At least try turn it into boots
and let it die with dignity.
[ Laughter ]
Firefighters in North Carolina
recently rescued
a newlywed couple
that got stuck
in an elevator for 2.5 hours
after their wedding.
The couple is doing fine
and ready to get on
with their divorce.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a woman in Georgia
was arrested last week
after she allegedly drove her
car into a Popeyes restaurant
because her order
did not have biscuits.
[ Laughter ]
Apparently, those biscuits
are the only thing that
take the edge off the meth.
[ Laughter ]
That was the monologue,
everybody.
We're off and running.
[ Cheers and applause ]